[Music]
foreign
well I mean it's kind of hard for Ryan
and I to really understand
is it is it really is it that is it that
terrible being a minority in America I
just I think for white people we we know
it but we really don't it depends where
you live Lee it depends where you live
Ferguson Missouri is probably the
equivalent to you know something like
Harlem I've never been there it's like
any other place USA where they have an
African-American [__] community and
then inside the African-American
Community they have three blocks of
[__] hell where people gonna buy
crack and there's hookers and God knows
what else is down there and listen man
I mean I'll be I'll say this too you
know you're from Baltimore well and
let's let's be honest let's go you know
I I am from Baltimore but when I say
Baltimore not those neighborhoods of
Baltimore
you know what I mean so I can't speak
intelligently on what's going on just
because you're from a city doesn't mean
you can speak intelligently on what's
going on in those
you know pockets and those areas of that
City yeah people always ask me I don't
hang out when you when people hear
Baltimore they think the wire yeah I
have never hung out in a neighborhood
like that I mean they're there that's
all real but I'm saying I don't go into
those neighborhoods there's no reason
for me to be in those neighborhoods
right there's like people always ask
what's going on in those neighborhoods
people always ask me when they hear
Boston is Boston racist and I've heard
stories and I'm sure in some parts it is
just the white people just
I've never I never I never saw it but
then again I'm white as [__] and I
probably wouldn't see it when somebody
says racist is it Five Guys in the bar
giggling and all of a sudden they say oh
did you see that [__] chicken last
night is it that type of racist or is it
racist that people actually put a
[__] hood on and go on pick fights no
Boston everybody gets alone because you
got black guys in the Boston Celtics
what's the [__] black guys got put on
the boss himself and big copy that's it
what that's it that was it they were
like you know what I don't know about
these black dudes but they could
playlist let's give them a [__]
chance you know but in all seriousness I
mean
in 1985 I used to hang out in San
Francisco and I used to hang out with
these Cuban refugees Cubans had just
come over and they were putting them in
different pockets
and I remember that there was this one
guy that they would give you uh
20 nickel bags
and let's say at five dollars a piece it
comes out to 125 or something they would
give you like 50 bucks out of the 125.
there were days when I was broke and I
just go out there just to hang out with
the guys you could 25 nickel bags in an
hour you know just so just to hang out
with the guys that say give me a a thing
and they give them to you and you'd hide
them you'd hide them on the bumpers you
know in cars you'd hide them so if the
cops come you could just you know you
don't have them on you right and listen
man every four [__] days cops pulled
up and I'm a white [__] dude on paper
until you take my license it says Jose
Diaz in those days I didn't carry your
license but my
my point is they would just pull up and
jump out of cars and throw you against
the wall it's tough to be a cop in
America
yeah I I yeah and
what what's gotten taken away from the
cops when I was banging heads and I was
out there getting pulled over and
robbing and all that [__] is the sense
of community okay so Ryan lives where
now yeah Santa Monica okay so you live
in Santa Monica you come up to the
Valley tomorrow
let me see how I could do this okay you
live in Santa Monica you live on a block
that there's a Rouse and all this [__]
and there's a neighborhood cop same
[__] cup
same [__] cop that's been there for
years and he sees you and he waves at
your kids and sometimes he pulls over
and you get in the car and let the kid
[__] beat the horn and you know but
you know his name is Phil officer
[__] Jones and you get to know him
three four [__] years now God forbid
you come up to the valley
coming to the valley one day we're all
hanging out another way out the door so
you get into an argument with some kid
and you smack him and you get in the
conductation license plate
they go up to the valley here in North
Hollywood they do the paperwork they
come down to Santa Monica to put that
warrant Guess who's coming to your house
with the cops in the valley officer
Smith because that's his neighborhood
and guess what officer Smith is going to
do officers the guys that are coming
down
Phil the cops that are coming from the
valley they're coming from the valley of
one side of a story in their head do you
follow me they're coming from the story
that some kid was walking down the block
on a skateboard and uh my man [__]
Ryan just [__] slapped him and got in
his car and the cops could know that guy
from the valley okay so it could be like
right so what a shame the kids are great
kids now they're coming down here with
what with blood in their eyes
all right but guess who stops them Phil
it's the film goes hold on one second to
knock on his door I gotta come with you
and he explains them this has to be a
misunderstanding I know him I know his
wife on those kids he's a stand-up comic
he's a decent guy so now the blood gets
tan they want to hear your side of the
story they'll take you down booking so
you understand me you had that type of
relationship with the police officers I
don't know what's happened the last 10
years I'm not out there but I know
there's no relationship with police
officers there's no more neighborhood
cop so I know I know what a black
neighborhood is I went into them to get
drugs I know how they Shake You Down
you know in the old days they get you
they have gone on their holsters now
they're coming out shoot guys and if
they see any infraction how many
shootings have you seen the last three
years are you like where's the
justification for this [__] shooting
a lot where's the justification for this
[__] shooting there's none he got on
the floor and the guy what's the one the
guy shot him a couple weeks ago the kid
to Cincinnati I can't look at the
stories anymore yeah one dude he told
him to reach for his license he went to
reach for it then he shot him and he
even said what he well he's hit with
he's hit he's like you told me to go for
my license I'm getting my license yeah
so who the [__] knows the pressures of
this to be a cop
but also when you watch these these
videos for me at least when I see a
cop's body Cam and I see it from their
point of view
to me at any moment it's like the end of
Sopranos who's it going to be that's
gonna you know what I mean I think that
it's so heightened right now that I
would I'd be scared out there I'd
definitely be if I got pulled over today
I'd be scared yeah I'd be the guy though
I mean I'd be scared if I would put my
hands right off the [__] window yeah
and let the body the cam watch it put my
hands out the window you know I would do
everything just I was thinking about it
the other day what if I get pulled over
and then when I come home from The
Comedy Store I would just as soon as I
open my window and put my hands on I'm
with you and that's it that's the end of
it then when they get there can I reach
for my license I'm reaching for my
license I'm I'm the same way but even if
they're even if things weren't
heightened
when isn't there always going to be some
sort of like tension between
the cops and I want to say just black
people but it's to see like right now in
this part right now in our world today
in the United States there's a hidden
tension with black people and and cops
and if you don't think I'm you'd have to
yeah you'd have to okay
you got a call tomorrow there's some
[__] Cuban dude smacking Jewish
people he goes into synagogues and just
smacks you and runs out he goes into
temples and I walk up on you as your
defense going to be out but you're going
to be glad to the same you don't know if
I'm gonna smack you right same [__]
thing every black person in America
right now whether they're a criminal
or just a regular black person after you
see the shooting in Cincinnati yeah you
have to be a little scared
subconsciously you could say suck my
dick they're gonna suck my white dick on
my black dick but some Consciousness
that goes into your subconscious mind so
you have to be a little bit [__]
scared I was always scared of cops
always me too yeah me too I've never
been home me too I suck that was the
name all right by the way you gotta hit
me up with that yeah
no we had no [__] name we were lip
syncing singing The Beatles over [__]
music with the Jackson Five like more
[__] Momos but my point being he said
that he kept watching his kids watching
TV
and it was completely different they
watched television a different way they
watched it on demand the Sun and he went
to sci-fi and kept telling them things
have changed and sci-fi was like nah
we're going to keep doing it so he quit
and he [__] started this YouTube
channel for horror people
and he's doing great with it seven
dollars a month unlimited however he
gets it from all over the world he's
been a horror buff since we were growing
up that was his thing he went to the
movies in Jersey City hey tell you and
you're like Jesus but he was such a nice
guy and he had such a passion for what
he did and now he's making a living from
just because he saw the future
so even as a comic I'm very fortunate
you are too that we're part of the
podcasting oh I look at a lot of comics
still and go you don't have a podcast
and you're not part of one you know
right now you're suspect even if your
podcast sucks you're suspect because you
don't have one people like why wouldn't
you have a [__] podcast everybody has
a podcast at least is trying to put one
together or as a part of one that calls
one in if you're a comedian I'm not
talking about if you're you know a stock
broker working 12-hour days busting your
ass well [__] [__] like me and
making people laugh you guys work for
real you got no [__] time
it's just crazy how
like how much competition is for kids
like how much they they have to know now
like I was when I was talking to their
to the parents I I brought up Cassius
Morris and how he's been doing since he
was 10. and like part of what I was
doing up there was training like the 13
year old girls to run the board and do
everything that we're doing and it's
just it's and they're already animating
stem and it's crazy how much
stuff there is for that for them now and
then and how great like if if you
started a podcast like you said you met
somebody this weekend who's been
following you for 15 years if there's a
comedian now who's 16 or 18 and starts a
podcast by the time he gets to be 30
he'll definitely have people who were
there from the beginning how [__]
crazy is that
I
I got a call from Roger Paul maybe 16
years ago Roger Paul's a [__] kinky
guy and whenever the phone rings it's
always going to be a by the way
so they want to hire you in Milwaukee I
had worked with a guy on a Yoda run
oh wait okay what's a Yoda Yoda Yoda is
a guy to Michigan oh Yoder okay ten
years ago the father old man you know
the 15 20 years ago if you're a comic
and you were from the Midwest
it was them and somebody else but Yoda
controlled the Midwest whether you were
dirty or clean if he liked you you
covered your nuts he had 63 rooms
and 22 weeks like all those cities in
Michigan there was a comedy club that he
booked that's it and they will all some
would be rooms some were [__] D rooms
some were Abrams uh
and he had Buffalo he had Cleveland I
mean he had so many rooms so
I did a Yoda run and I met this dude
from Milwaukee
and I said what I gotta do to get into
that room and walk in here because I
recommend you and three months later
some guy calls me and says hey they're
looking for you to see if you want to
work that room
so I went up there and the dead of the
winter February Valentine's Day weekend
like that that weekend
oh my God the [__] the by the way was
the condo
it looked like the monsters
it even had the gate and [__] the whole
[__] deal everything oh my god I've
talked about this it was just horrific
but anyway
uh when I was up there that time I met
the lady who actually books that and she
used to book that room at the time in
Appleton
she's still around her daughter's now a
Booker in that area very small venues
you know colleges [__] like that so when
she offered me the week she said if you
come in Tuesday I got a show I do at
Marquette
you could do the show 125 bucks one of
those deals you know
so I went and did the show and in those
days all I did was snort blow and hang
out at the store
that's it so my whole comedy routine was
about feeding them and looking out
windows and you know
and nobody was laughing but I'm not no I
don't remember I do not remember I don't
even listen sometimes I can't even hear
whether people laughing I knew it wasn't
my audience but now this weekend in
Minneapolis some kid pulls me aside from
the Friday night early show
and says that he was there that night
and he came to uh
the comedy club that we can see me and
he remembered the girl with the red hair
and it was just really nice that he was
like I made a mental note I always knew
you would do something it was very nice
that is nice you don't bump into people
like that no I made a mental note of you
a while ago I mean you you know I've
known you
but I've you know I've always sort of
kept to myself we've done several shows
together but there was one we did
the Hollywood improvi years ago and a
girl went up and she was pretty dirty
and you followed her and you got up and
you said uh that's the type of chick at
all let your [__] in the ass pull it
out and suck it and then the crowd went
nuts and you laughed and but that was
your way of saying like I loved her you
know that's what you said at me like I
loved her I loved her dude I laughed so
[__] hard at that for like five
goddamn minutes because it's probably
100 true
so funny
oh my God
oh my God that was your just walk up and
say it off the top of your head and it
was so sometimes you gotta break a room
up it was perfect listen every unless
you're [__] up
you always
if you're you come if you have a little
sarcasm Gene there's things people say
that no matter what age they say it
something comes to your mind and you
want to crack a joke whether it's to
yourself whether it's to the room
whatever the [__] it is you know uh
today the baby was looking at me she
kept looking at me going blow daddy
blow and I'm like in 20 years you won't
be saying like you think of things like
that yeah you know
a hot girl goes up on a stage her tits
are out she's talking about getting
[__] in the ass you're sitting there
you're a man even if you're on a date
what are you thinking about [__] her
in the ass and sticking your dick in her
mouth all I'm doing is going on stage
and saying what you think the reason why
I Gotta Laugh was because this is as I
walked out this was everybody was
[__] thinking
everybody was [__] thinking oh my God
yeah who knows
I hate when Comics go up with the set
routine sometimes you have to react to
the [__] room yeah I agree with you
this com there's natural comedy in the
room nothing bothers me more when I see
something coming
there's always even just regular
conversation sometimes
there's a great
comedic banter in a conversational
energy that somebody else might not be
laughing but you might even feel that oh
yeah exactly all the time a little
comedy light banter that you're like oh
my God that's so that thing in a movie
was such a brilliant conversation they
had you know it was so as people say
that's the stuff that makes me laugh
most that you say now because I I'll
come and see shows a lot so I'll get to
know some bits but the stuff that makes
me laugh is the stuff that you just say
that you'll never say again yeah that's
the those are my favorite people in the
world like my grandmother and her
sisters were the same way I couldn't
wait to hear what like you know we've
all been through situations but I
couldn't wait to hear their response
on Mrs Obama she handle us he gained
like 10 pounds no I don't care but she's
looking good in those polyester suits
you see him on [__] Good Morning
America oh my God she looks good oh my
God what's happening you bad
[__] Thursday morning the man
the legend himself Mr Ryan sickler
straight out of Baltimore more before
the [__] wire you know what I'm
saying he lit the wire this [__]
lit the wire and left
thank you for having me on what's going
on brother good to see you that's good
to see you dude you know for this is
what I want to say first before I say
anything about myself I watch your
degenerate special I thought it was
fantastic thank you uh and I don't want
to blow your cover but a lot of people
know this and some people maybe they
don't you are the nicest [__] guy
like you really care about people I tell
everybody like Joey Diaz you see that
guy on stage that's that dude but you
know what that dude also does calls you
call not text you call how you doing
every time you're checking on me all the
time man I can't thank you enough to
your friends you're great though a lot
of people don't do that you're really
good at it listen man I'm sick and tired
you're a sweetheart I have no friends
you got a lot of people you don't you
don't friendship doesn't
come because you're such a nice guy
either you can have millions of dollars
and buy your friends or you could earn
people's friendship and one way one way
to earn people's friendship is when the
peanut butter jar broke
peanut butter is on the floor your kids
yelling you're late for an audition
you're going crazy and also the phone
rings and somebody just doesn't want
something from you they just call you
they go hey man
I was thinking about you
it's so right there in that moment
even though everything's going on for
somebody to say dog then I at the comedy
store I saw you and I forgot to tell you
your set was brilliant you know sat
something about Saturday night
a couple weeks ago I went up there and
uh
who's the guy that had the show when we
first started comedy with the long hair
Tom Rhodes was up before yeah
brilliant the set he did was brilliant
Tom's green took me five days to
remember to call him and call them like
hey man I'm calling you to say hello but
I'm calling you to say that you're set
the other night
was brilliant
that comedians don't humans don't have
that normal when I got a text message
that says happy birthday
or Happy Thanksgiving
Merry Christmas that I'm guilty of it
too I say you know what I hope your
mother gets hit by an Amtrak
because you got to know what she raised
you the wrong way don't you [__] text
me Merry holidays you pick up that phone
and you don't call don't even bother
don't waste your time I want to hear
your voice
I want to know what you're feeling I'm
friends with you I know what makes you
think I I think it's beautiful and if
you don't do that you're not gonna have
everybody wants to have friends whatever
he wants to have friends I want to have
a friend that if I stab a [__]
my wife says Ryan's sickler called your
bell is a half a mill but he's got 25
that he can lend you till you get out
and do a benefit you know
um there you go that's not friends those
aren't the same people that come to your
birthday party at La Mirage you know
what I'm saying oh my God to a wonderful
man let's raise our champagne glasses
that don't happen that's only in the
movies that's what you're looking for
you're gonna die with nobody you're
gonna die alone because those people
only come when your pockets are full
they're not going to be there when your
pockets are empty I look at how many
people are aware around me with my
pockets were empty and I was struggling
comedy and I look at where they are you
know what I'm saying those people now
come to the shows and juries like last
week I did Gotham I saw people there
that I used to make go to open mics you
know when they make you bring four
people yeah
there were kids in that crew that I
would bring to those things
like 20 years ago you got to do me big
favors
before you go to the city tonight stop
at stand up New York and just pay for a
ticket it's eight bucks
and there we go for you I'll do it and
they would bring like six of them would
show up and they'd spend 600 at the bar
and they'd be snowing in the bathroom
and
look at the club owner would go listen
you can come here whenever you want as
long as your friends come
on
because they've spent four or five
months
I still talk to those people you know
those people were there when when I was
doing open mics
dude I'm still friends with guys from
elementary school I'm still strong we're
good friends with guys from elementary
school middle school and high school
there's a couple College people but the
core of my friends back home and I see
every every time I go home I see a good
chunk of them you know everybody's got
kids and things now but still we still
make time to get together but they're
all from back in the day all of them and
every day I go I got a call this guy
it'll take me three days to call but in
the meantime I'll call other people
will take me three days to go I gotta
call on this [__] guy wait a second
this guy works nights I'll call him on
my way to The Comedy Store all right on
my drive yeah you know Timmy Works nice
but that's beyond considering someone
it's also their schedule and when you
can actually think you've got a shot at
getting a hold of them instead of just
throwing on a voicemail that no one
listens to anymore anyway you know what
I mean like remember when it used to be
like
you had to be somewhere to get that
[__] call you had to be right here to
get this call then it came call wait and
you were like oh my God two people think
enough of me to call me at the same
[__] time like holy [__] hang on a
second then you got the answer machine I
was like let's listen to this message
now I see people on their phone with 300
Miss [__] calls and and 80 voicemails
I'm like what the [__] happened what
happened I don't know if you guys ever
run into this it blew my mind just
because I grew up on the phone there's a
lot of people especially my age and a
little bit younger who say they get
anxiety about being on the plug they
don't want it they won't make calls to
anybody
that that doesn't make sense to me but I
people get anxiety about anything I
guess but
I like the personal aspect of life I
think that
if you don't want it in your life you
don't have to have it for me I prefer
that contact
you know I like talking to my uh to my
friends I grew up with
instead of talking to these people in
L.A and like
you could do
so much in L.A to have people in your
corner that say yes to you yeah you
could hire four people and have a big
payroll and everybody's saying yes to
you and getting your coffee and you can
yell and make scenes and he's having a
bad day to who gives a [__]
you know what keeps me grounded is in
the morning when I call one of my
buddies from high school
damn like I told Brody Stevens that
deliver in a FedEx package
and they're making 12.50 an hour at 55
and they're running up and down stairs
and I go to a comedy main room on a
Tuesday and pick up 300 or something
like that you know and I'm sick thinking
to myself it it brings my
it levels me it does it's a balance yeah
we've uh years ago 10 12 13 years ago
accompanying a company around a ran a
commercial
and it's a sales force
and the guy walks back in and he starts
giving everybody a plane ticket Lee Syed
here you go
Ryan sickler here you go Tony bananas
here you go Johnny goombat you're going
they're all looking at that plane
tickets
and he goes ladies and gentlemen I
looked at the stats of the company and I
looked at the national stats sales are
down
because we do everything on these like
this was a commercial
and he goes we're going back out there
talking to people and we're going to get
back in people's faces that's how you
sell accounts good luck gentlemen they
were like looking around like each other
and it said like the name of the company
if their sales and make account but it's
true we've forgotten
all those personal little things that
person those little things when I sold
cars
I was two things guess what I used to do
a lot a lot more than I do now I was a
letter writer you were I loved writing
letters to who whoever you would do it
for someone like I could say hey okay
this is contact prison inmates yeah I
was gonna say I'm not I'm not trying to
make a joke was it from you being in
prison no this was something that I
learned from a guy named Carmine balzano
[Music]
this guy got caught with [__] you
know uh not paying parking tickets
ripping tickets up like you'd come to
them and going out a thousand dollars in
tickets and he'd rip them up this guy
lived corruption but what he did was
write letters to editors
and he would get his stories always
printed he was a letter writer
and I would look at that and he'd always
say the uh
the pen is mightier than the sword
sometimes you know he'd say in his words
sometimes the pen is mighty and the gun
you know like he was he was a cop
and something he did something just I
got into writing letters to pick up
these little appliances kind of like
fridges and [__] yeah did someone buy
them or you just found them no we would
get subcontracted okay and you would
deliver the water dryer yeah we'd have
to go to this place we pull up at the
point
and just 30 air conditioners in the
world is that
I go in I give the guy the bills no
cameras in those days either I give the
guy the bill of Lady he gives me the
paperwork the [__] kit comes over help
you with the refrigerator cabbage then
then the guy gets in his car one of his
buddies I'm going to get high
50 [__] air conditions and I think I
go Michael went up the back of that
thing what are you gonna do you shut
your mouth we started putting the
[__] air conditioners in that thing
10 20. I was with the UPS man I took
every last air conditioner all in
Brooklyn
and we turned that [__] around
and we just drove down the boulevard 100
a piece an air conditioner it's July it
was June it was like steel oh yeah we
sold them with them we split the [__]
money I went over to McGrath's house my
eighth grade teacher my uh
football coach the running back coach
and I bought a thousand of those little
gram bottles of Coke from them oh my God
and I went out with my friends I told I
was in the meeting with Joe and Mary's
but I took like a [__] Quaalude and
me and my buddies got [__] up I woke
up the next one I left this stiff so if
we did the same [__] every week Tuesday
was McSorley's album chalets was in
Jersey City
30 cents for an Alabama Slammer and five
cents for a mug of beer till 10 o'clock
damn at pedal one five you couldn't find
a friend yeah
the place was vacant
it was [__] crazy we're out of here
at 9 45 people get three mugs and three
drinks like you see people drinking on
three straws and [__] two Wednesday was
ladies night the Dome
and Thursdays was another lady's night
so we detected them because they were 50
Cent Straight
so come here
's a 10. go buy you one here
you know for seven dollars
really yeah I'm a big shot tonight so I
saw it down there and I apologized I'm
sorry in fact I saw on a Wednesday down
there and I said I'm sorry about last
night I [__] up
she got so how about dinner tomorrow I
took her to pick the least she moved
forward New Jersey like a doctor there
was adults that hadn't been the big
Alicia
I forget what the guy's name was the guy
has a weird name he's missing his
stomach though he owns the restaurant
that's a hell of a that's a hell of a
curse to own a restaurant and be missing
your stomach the stomach had a dish
called Lobster throughout Diablo know
what he burned his stomach no wonder he
doesn't understand okay oh Friday off
his valve the name of this thing was
Lobster front Diablo yeah his name was
Johnny
food
and I go down and eat a clam I can't I
can't you know
I was a kid and I'm going up there
[__] giving orders because we get
like a score and I'd go up there and
drop money give him a drink give them
all a drink you know Dad don't worry
about nothing and people get pissed it
was like that scene when Belushi went to
the restaurant and Blues Brothers yeah
oh yeah like it was white people Fort
Lee and I'm gonna go up there with 16
gorillas
so I took her on a date up there and
they brought you a dish I'm not even
exaggerating it was this big that looked
like a fish and in the middle was pasta
it was surrounded by clams mussels and
shrimp to the decked God
two big lobster tails that were cracked
open with red sauce on top oh no no no
no
you'd put your little thing on she was
in heaven she's eating this [__]
thing then we'd get out of there I take
it down by the Binghamton the Binghamton
was a boat that you could go on and have
a few drinks there was a movie theater
that's why I saw 48 hours and
Ghostbusters
after like 20 minutes
the rats from the Hudson River were
trying to chip away at your car it was
[__] good your car coming that's
crazy and friendly basis had a hole in
his car so we had to put a [__] piece
and we went down there to make out with
chicks
you know we used to drink beers and
throw them out of the hole
and people be driving on what the [__]
that's all that rust my buddy had a
Volkswagen with uh floorboards rusted
out too his foot fell through one time
on the highway
eyes yellow we're trying to stop the
cars flip through so I take this little
trenches her name is Lisa triches and
she got a sister named Sue she looks
just like Pat Benatar in the first video
of uh you better run with the red and
white shirt I even made it get a red and
white shirt
yeah you're looking like Pat you can't
see the Swap and spit and I started
eating her [__] and she started and I
remember she used to put talking powder
in her [__] because when I opened it up
a bunch of it came out the face you know
what I'm saying and that [__] is on
Facebook she ain't dying to be varying
cancer she's kicking Jersey but she got
a shot of talking pot that hit me in the
face and I ate her [__] she was banging
on the top of the car I was I had her
out there [__] both legs eating after
a Coke rock on her [__] no dick I cut
her off from the dick no dick tonight
I'm dropping you off at home and don't
even look at me sideways
and then I went over that [__] Friday
night I dropped her off like a gentleman
and we made plans Saturday night to eat
a [__] Saturday night I was gonna [__]
and we went out went to a party that got
into a fight in the party in my hand got
stuck in a barbed wire fence right here
as I was getting he was taking me down I
stuck my hand in the fence and winning
that my God damn it cops came
me and my boy and her and a piece of ass
she had Tasia Romano there's Romana was
a hot piece of ass
that's like your name
this was one of those [__] that for
six months she looked good and for six
months you show up looking like Lee
used to call it Tasia Romano big fat
piano because she would go then for
[__] six months she would not eat a
thing and she'd puke and vomit my guest
today is my main man
and the best interviewer I know Mr Ryan
sickler man thank you the flying Jew is
also in-house hello
what's up dog
thank you for having me back man that's
that's how I praise right there the best
interviewer you know the best you know I
don't open up to nobody like they open
up to you you've wept on my show a few
times you have been moved quite a bit I
I'm very uh impressed by it as always so
thank you for having me back
it's really fun when you people think I
love when people call you up and go hey
I just want to be on your podcast you
know what I don't even [__] know you
if you look at the podcast you have high
numbers with
it's people you have a feeling with
that's right you share mutual love with
because the love gets picked up on the
airwaves
and people call their friends and say
y'all listen to this podcast it's kind
of special
it's not special they've already they
always they've already heard the stories
it's the electricity between two people
speaking which is what I like
the most about podcasts that's why I
don't like
[__] 18 people in the room when I do
a podcast I don't like I like the
intimacy I want one conversation yeah
you know once you have six mics going
eight mics going you have nine different
energies and that it's that one-on-one
love and people feel that when I'm with
your podcast the girls podcast Tripoli
Eddie Bravo the numbers are always good
because the love is there Rogan and the
millions yeah red band in the millions
because the love is there
and people don't seem to get that
us as podcast is for the last eight nine
years
yesterday I got hit up by some [__]
uh I want to start a podcast where we
get hot and spicy chicken nuggets
oh yeah the whole lineup was watch that
thing I'll be doing two million
downloads yeah like nobody's done that
before eating a hot and spicy chicken
I'm [__] lying like you know what I'm
saying like I don't want to eat nothing
spicy chicken online I really did Hot
Wings it's a it's on True TV now I got a
feather in my cap that's it
anomaly Tyson spicy chicken are you
[__] [__] the host is the kiss of
death and the two other guys what are
they gonna do for me get the show
started and get back to me what if you
do three episodes and somebody dies from
that [__] Chinese chicken yourself
I gotta be a part of that when the
coconut seriously yeah I'm in the
[__] in the in the [__] you know
people just don't get it that there's a
limit that I disappear once it comes to
podcasts when you call me with like a
[__] game show type podcast you in no
danger oh yes you did that whatever I'll
put you you know if you're gonna be that
stupid I gotta call from a dear friend
of mine that wanted me to do a podcast
on a Sunday in a [__] like a sauna
with nothing no clothes on and I'm like
hey first little Sunday is the Lord's
Day number two on Sundays I don't really
know what I want to do today I'm just
flying back from the show the night
before 50 of the time and I really don't
know what I want to do Sunday mornings
are my favorite in the world because my
wife and baby leaves the church at nine
not the my type of church some other
religion whatever the [__]
Christianity was there's no chickens
involved yeah there's no chickens
involved there's no rape and there's no
crackers you know what I'm saying my
daughter brought home one of those
Catholic chocolates the other day it
tastes like being a priest penis
she's like look daddy I got what flavors
and in my head I said please
nobody could tell all that you know I
ended up eating the chocolate later on
when I woke up from my combo she's like
daddy where's that dick chocolate
somebody ate my chocolate oh I said the
priest
[Laughter]
so uh
oh my God so that's what well we're
gonna get your full life story we're
doing it I mean I I I don't you cut this
is probably going to come out the same
week or or your episode which we've
already recorded will come out no this
is your weekend it's coming out two
weeks after
I'm saying your episode for mine we
already recorded you another episode
with you on the Honeydew yes and that's
probably gonna come out in the same
about a week or two right and I think
we're only I mean what are we where I
call them the Denver days we just got
into Denver so your early 20s I think
and we're gonna do your we're gonna do
your whole life story until we get to
current we're gonna cry every day I put
away an hour to write something
and I've been pretty successful with it
wait wait it's been working
well
and you your memory isn't your memory
doesn't really open up until you start
opening it up and reading it back
uh
I've been catching the coffee shop where
I go in the afternoon one hour a day
lately just one one hour and 15 minutes
I park I get a green tea
and I just write out and I was started
on drugs
and it's
hilarious
there's nights I said he would leave and
I'd fortunately believe those knows I
love them Leo Coleman exchange I got so
[__] up on them legal I don't know how
you did it
until this day people cannot realize the
the the
even I feel it
like when people give me a pill that
says kill them
aspirin I did it I did a [__] I did
two pills about a year and a half ago I
went to do a podcast and the people were
Junkies
and they had a bag of pills and they
gave me like a pill and a half and I am
I gonna sit here and why I got [__] up
but that's the day your Romero came in
right and I had to do a podcast where
you go well then we had to go eat
chicken Cuban food and I was surprised
on how well I kept it together it was a
percocet and a Vicodin and something
else I was high for eight hours straight
yeah but I from my experiences as a
young man I kept it together
and I started writing this thing for
March 25th at The Comedy Store about
addictions you know my addiction
throughout all this story I haven't
mentioned to you guys
what at 14 if you were to come up to me
and said Joey
do you are you ever going to be
interested in doing coke or whatever I'd
probably beat the [__] out of you
but at 14
I probably started smoking pot at 12 and
a half let's just be safe
let's just be safe and not lie to each
other
12 and a half 13. very subtly
once a month
it went from once a month and is this
floating through the bar or is this
through school like or kids in the
neighborhood of the neighborhood
downtown all right we had the thing
called the woods
and we would roll
three joints and smoke them in a glass
pipe that you held up like a carburetor
you sucked on it and then you let the
thing going all the Airways yeah we were
making with toilet paper rolls we'll do
the same thing with toilet paper like
gravity hits with aluminum foil yeah so
we were doing all that
in those days it was very hush-hush it
was me and three other kids and same age
kids yeah we had the Visine the banaka
yeah yeah and then we go we'd walk to
this Diner on Tom Lee Avenue that did
not existent it was a real redneck
trucker Diner
and they had like the music on the wall
you know like when you spin it yeah you
play songs and we'd go in there listen
to
Margaritaville and just [__] another
wait just to come and she'd be like 40
and ugly she smoked like a thousand
cigarettes and cheese was three
three
and [__] we'd laugh at him we just
start laughing at him she'd give us the
menus and say I'll come back when you
grow up like [__] like that it started
like a fun thing and
then we start by the eighth grade we're
doing it
uh in between classes sometimes
the three of us would get together and
smoke a joint go back to class lit up
and start making noises in class and
giggling the whole thing
and then it was just a slow process I
knew that I just liked marijuana I knew
the dangers of cocaine and the dangers
of heroin
but then a friend of mine came to me one
day and he goes Let's do an acid I was
the Rolling Stones
in the eighth grade
my eighth grade graduation that was his
present for me
because I'm taking you to see the stones
we gotta take a hit a window playing
acid I'm like oh here we go
I go hop back to the bridge it was bad
but I went to the concert I you know and
then I then I kind of like that I like
where it took me I like that I could go
home and listen to music
and I would pop acid again once a month
for a while
then it became twice a month
and then it became a thing that we would
do three nights a week damn we're
tripping three nights for how long how
many years this one for a year this year
this is so crazy to me yeah
yeah half the week is on acid this is
freshman
year about November
we were doing hits acid three a week
three a week and is it just one hit a
night or you're doubling up on those no
no okay one all right one would take you
you did it at six you'd be cooking till
three and I mean cooking like you could
go home by yourself
somebody told me a story one time oh
acid shrooms opium things like that
didn't come through our way until the
Grateful Dead came to town we would all
go to the parking lot we'd party at the
Capitol Center back in the day where
they did Heavy Metal parking lot that's
the capital Center we're there for the
Grateful Dead and I I didn't smoke or
anything but everybody I hung out with
didn't I never minded that they did I
kind of enjoyed like seeing what
happened I'm like okay well I'm not
gonna do cocaine well I'm not gonna do
[__] refills I'm not
um but one of our friends
um somebody told me this I I I hope this
is [__] true but I guess he had
bought a sheet of acid put it in his
pocket to take back with us later that
night and it rained and the rain washed
the [__] acid into his skin
and he was they said he was they they
had to take to the hospital
can't really happen come on that chicken
I guess it could right I just I know
that I was clean and sober
I was cleaning sober okay I was clean
and sober they threatened me with
[__] going back to prison and
finishing my sentence
and one day I get a call like that's the
positive for cocaine
and I go
I don't I don't snort the cocaine I just
sell it and I told that to a friend of
mine he goes are you [__] he goes
every time he touched those rocks that
stuff goes through your skin on that
spot one time I tested positive I wasn't
even doing it it was from touching it so
yes I do believe that story
especially back then
the acid was thicker
I never [__] the look you gave me
shrooms you just gave me shrooms a
comedy store at the last okay was it
they were good good yeah I had them that
I had some that night and then I still
have what you gave me to take home with
me [__] I got a bag of thous
um but I want to I'll tell you this so
when I first moved out here
um because I've only done shrooms like
five times and at one point I enjoyed it
but also I'm just like I'm the guy
that's like all right it's been five
hours get the [__] out here you know I'm
like that with company you know I mean
get the all right it's you know we had a
good time get the [__] out of here you
don't need I don't need still being here
in my music like after five [__]
hours you know
um you know I get it but back when I
first lived here this was
this was in the 1900s man this was 97
bro late 1900s 1997 I first moved here
to go to college uh and that was the
whole Northridge Quake I I was coming
here to go to Northridge when the Quake
hit and destroyed the school so I ended
up
uh going anyway but I I was I found an
apartment for a month then moved in in
February and Pink Floyd is coming out to
the Rose Bowl and I love Pink Floyd and
I want to go see Pink Floyd and I want
to see him at the [__] Rose Bowl so
my buddy and I get tickets and he tells
me uh a married couple that he knows is
going to meet us there and sit with us
as well I was like great so the four of
us are hanging out we're all smoking
weed and three of them decide to do
shrooms and I'm like I'm good I'm just
gonna smoke weed and drink
get into the show the show's [__]
banana I don't know if you've ever seen
pink I got to see him here and in DC at
RFK when that was still there uh same
Summer and the pigs are [__] bouncing
you know they're all tripping over there
on their oh sorry on their shrooms and
[__]
and I look to my left
and you've been in a Rose Bowl you're
packed in there you know and I look back
to my right and my friend Kevin he's
gone he's gone
and I and people start yelling and [__]
I look back this [__] passed out
okay and it's those bleacher seats so
when he went back his feet got hooked
under the back of the front one and he
bent in half and people instead of
catching them they got scared and they
jumped out of the way his head hits the
bleachers behind him he goes into a
full-on seizure okay he's going crazy
his eyes and they're like is he up is he
epileptic I'm like I don't [__] know
I have no idea were you tripping no I
only smoked weed and drank but the three
of them they're all to my right it's him
and then the Mary couples she sees it
and I I think guilt got to her and
everything because she's the one that
gave him the shrooms she starts throwing
up in her like 50 concert shirt she her
she's they're all having now they're all
having a bad trip because he's having a
full-on [__] seizure uh welcome to
the Church of What's Happening Now
everybody I'm Ryan sickler sitting in
tonight not really in but in and next to
uh the one and only Joe Coco Diaz here
also Lee Syed this is a special edition
I guess of the church you've never had
anyone do this before no this is an
honor I'm military let's make sure you
should live Freddie Prince yeah hosting
yeah I'm your first guest host yes the
[__] love it and I love that you're
here for it though a lot of times guest
hosts and you're not here somebody else
so uh we have been documenting your life
on the Honeydew we have uh done about 40
hours of we're only at 1980 [__] six uh
we we got through 1985 and 86 last time
on the Honeydew so why don't we pick up
here with January of 1987.
January of 1987 I found myself working
at a car wash and bowl to drying off
cars
I was one of those guys outside freezing
freezing drying off cars I started the
job
like the second week of December and I
work damn minimum wage plus tips
all right so just let me refresh here
how old are you in 87 now how old are
you 24. okay
yeah 24.
63 and 4 24. so I'm wiping down Windows
washing on cars and the only hustle I
have are the tips how can I steal the
tips
you know what I'm saying if you break up
the tips I go from making seven to like
980 that's not gonna work for Uncle Joey
I hate to kick up my income so I figured
out that if I drive the car and the guy
tips me if nobody's watching it goes in
my pocket oh he's a hateful [__] the job
you know what I'm saying also everybody
yeah here I am getting the nickel and I
gotta share it with these [__] books
that are moving at the speed of me
so that lasted for a few weeks I saw an
ad or somebody told me
about a body shot
that was hiring a detailing apprentices
now I wasn't [__] getting rich at the
car wash
I went down to this uh whatever the [__]
it was
and I apply and the guy happens to be
from New York just the body shop The
Body Shop paint shop detailing shop
and he goes I am looking for a guy but
it's it may not be you
I got a position for a position called
the shagger
and uh where you you watch Cars you help
the body guys you got to be here at six
in the morning it doesn't pay overtime
it pays like 220 a week
and you're here till you're here and you
work hard to become a detailer and
that's where you make your money
well I started there like in November uh
January
right before the Super Bowl the Giants
went to the Super Bowl against somebody
and
uh
well maybe the Bronco somebody when I
started the week or two before the Super
Bowl because they invited me to their
Super Bowl party there were nice guys
and you know whatever I fit in but I
didn't you know
um
I did I did my job I was really good at
it I used to have to go to car dealers
so this particular Body Shop worked for
a chain called the crouches in Boulder
at that time they had Suzuki
Subaru
you know uh Acura he had like four or
five Mitsubishi he had like four or five
different chains
and we wash those cars in Honda Metro
Honda we had or something Honda
so I became friendly with all the guys
hey how you doing what's going on I
would help the detailers and pick up
cars
and I became friendly with this guy from
Jersey at a Subaru dealership
I would go to the Subaru dealership they
do like the ice cream man got that
what's up [__] what up oh [__]
there he is Jersey Joe oh [__] there was
a skinny guy from Detroit that looked
like a junkie real good looking he was
cool the guy's name was Peter Pinto the
manager there was a dude named Carlos
and I just became friends with them the
lot boy there was working a tremendous
scam he was selling he was getting like
he was one of those guys that was making
350 an hour but he was making 80 000 a
year yeah he was one of those guys you
got an above ground pool [__] he was
getting maybe 10 an hour but he drove
like a Porsche because he was taking the
Subarus this sl10 the high-end stereos
and you bought the car he would come up
to you and go let me talk to you about
some what do you want to do here this
stereo sucks what if I could put an sl10
in there if a hundred falls out of your
pocket and he would so I'll send the
bank came one day and they're like all
the sl10 [__] radios are missing
they're all shitty am radios it's
[__] hilarious this place was a big
uh
put the am radios in place
this place is crazy
so now they yelled at me when are you
gonna become a Salesman and I'm like I'm
no [__] car salesman stop that [__]
that's the third guy I'm like that three
years that kept bothering me to go sell
cars
I'm like I'm not gonna go [__] sell
cars you people [__] crazy
so I came and I got promoted to a
detailer
and that's when you get like I forget
what uh but the pay raise was huge I
went from making 220 to like a thousand
a week
now I'm doing some powder
I got a little apartment in South
Boulder my girlfriend would come over
I'd give her a couple bumps
either little monkey should go home and
I'd do the rest of I'd hold out on a I
only got a little bit together I have to
go to school anyway you suck I thought
you got more get the [__] out and then
I do my thing and
it was great I love detailing I really
liked it I liked the being alone I like
listening to music everybody that smoked
pot you know it was really cool but one
of my best pieces of work there
was once I started leaning
I became a detailer right away like they
said it takes 90 days it took me like 24
days and they had no choice I was out
working everybody I was just one of
those dudes that he wrote a monkey on my
back I'm not working it I ain't working
for 220 a week
but the thing that kept me there was a
burrito lady
it was a burrito lady that came every
day at like nine o'clock with green
chili and mashed potatoes
in a burrito Lee your head would explode
it was in a blender
she put it in a blender you could taste
the little pieces of pork in there so
it's just a tortilla and she let you run
a tab on and you could pay her on Friday
oh [__] oh she was beautiful I loved it
but then I was getting hot cigarettes at
the time I had a friend who was giving
me hot cigarettes I go you sell
cigarettes on the Roach Coach he goes
yeah I'll trade you cigarettes for
[__] burrito
burrito plant it never ends the hustle
never ends dog you don't understand
never and never ended no what's the
conversion how many cigarettes for a
burrito I don't know I forget those days
she was I don't know what she was giving
me for cotton I and then I would get the
burritos for like a dollar off they were
like two dollars a dollar delete
delicious I mean you couldn't live
without it that made me hungry
I would snort cold thinking about that
burrito
at the end of this [__] I'm getting six
of those [__] for breakfast and
got every once in a while she'd run out
of them but she wants to get them I stop
like well you'll make a six potato I'm
all out what do you mean y'all you know
I need two to [__] make this party
happen here
I don't want the red pork do I look like
I want red pork I'm trying to [__]
you know what I'm saying
that was like and I became Partners the
dude who was on steroids
and one night I went to his house after
work he's like he kept telling me he
wanted me to do him a favor wait I'm
just hold on one second Partners in the
detailing business now no he was a
detailer okay big yo kid and he went off
and did your own thing now no no no me
and him
got it got it he watched my back I
watched he was a big white boy
good [__] dude good family but I went
to his high heels can you come over with
me and help me with some stuff with that
I go yeah I didn't know what to expect I
go over there he goes listen man
me and my girlfriend broke up and she's
the only way to shoot me with steroids
huh can you shoot me with steroids I
don't know about shooting nobody I can't
even see needles he's like really oh I
can do it you can do it I'll talk you
through it
I mean
and then I'm like I don't want to do
this and he's like you should you should
do some steroids you got a great build
you lift and I'm like I'm not shooting
it and I drank a bottle of steroid juice
that must have definitely [__] myself
I just drank it my face turned red for
like an hour
so this is I'm talking I'm [__] juicy
I'm out of my mind guys I'm snorting
coke on the weekends Molly steroid juice
God knows what's gonna happen so it's
supposed to be shot intravenously yeah
so this is how [__] nuts I was
at the time I'm living with like
another couple and they're just doing
coke all the time she's walking around
with her panties he would pass out she'd
come talk to me with the panties and I
you know it was just not a good scene so
I got my own apartment I moved somewhere
else
and embrace me up a little bit like my
numbers you know like now I had to pay
real rent I was paying like for a room
and a house now I had to pay real rent
and I was making money detailing but
this cut into my [__] Coco local time
because I used to go to [__] that one
place that serves the french fries with
the endless
Red Robin Red Robin he used to make Coco
Locos I'd make a tip like two extra
vodkas in there
oh
[Music]
good
Ness
[Music]
foreign